I appreciate I don't give a fuck style
more than any other style of comedy for
me my favorite shit was like first of
all Joey Diaz but then that when you go
back to the greats like Kinnison and
Hicks and this guy's didn't give a fuck
now they went out they went off and it
was the most fun to watch as a person
who was an audience member for me was
the most fun to watch I agree and I
think you know that's that's the shit
that it's yeah we grew up on that and
then society changes and I'm like no
dude I've been I've been working on this
for so long
please let me I have to change my entire
like foundation of what I think is funny
now because and it's only so and that's
why I think guys like Legion of skanks
and the special you guys name it Legion
skanks me and big J okay so big J would
constantly cheat on his wife and it was
like a regular occurrence and she knew
it and everyone know it and one time we
were there and we were hanging out and
we were about to leave they were in her
argument she's like fuck you why don't
you go hang out with your legion of
skanks and me and big J we were both
playing guitar hero at the time it was
like a big game we both looked at each
other we're like Guitar Hero name and
that's what we named our band initially
in Guitar Hero on was Legion of skanks
and then we're not that creative so we
wrote a script how long ago was probably
10 years ago 10 years ago 10 years ago
the name and then that was the guitar
hero band maybe even more probably more
you actually way more because it was
right with me and big J became friends
and then we were yeah
Legion of skanks is a great name it's
probably one of the all-time greatest
names of anything right you stop and
think about like bands or television
Legion of skanks that is a great thank
you thank you great name yeah well I got
to give it a big jack is he recognized
it immediately and then every project we
ever did since then has been named Lee
Gina skanks until the podcast worked
good move yeah and it uh yeah it's you
know people know what they're getting
they get it dude they get it and to be
honest with you people people want that
type of humor that's the other thing is
like it's the new alternative is like
dirty edge you're ballsy shit well it's
what we're talking about earlier look if
you like punk rock you should be able to
listen to punk rock but if you like the
kind of comedy that some people like
aggressive like outlandish comedy you're
like if that's what you like then you
should be able to enjoy it you're not
up to you it's like you don't have to
like it you don't have to listen you
have to watch it's not that it makes you
immune from criticism if people don't
like it but you know it's everybody's
got different tastes that's it and and
to be honest with you if I wanted to sit
here and deconstruct everything that
could trigger me in life I'm just not a
bitch I don't I don't sit here and I'm
triggered every moment by the amount of
shit that I've seen in my fucking life
everything triggers me everything
triggers me and every movie that I
watched is if there's some fucked up
scene I can go that reminds me of some
fucked up shit but you have to
appreciate those things don't you sort
of want sort of everything to be
represented